Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P, here is a caller.
Calling in about whether I will be
fleeing the Northeast to Florida.
Speaker 2: Even this album Jersey,
I just heard you say that you are,
in fact, moving to Florida. You are going to
move into the villages with Pat and some of
the dolphins and ride around a golf carts and
yell at white power. I can't believe that you
will be a snowbird because you're missing the best
part of the East Coast. Winter is the best season.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, I am not moving to
Florida as of this time. If I did move to Florida
on a part or full time basis, I would not live at
the villages. I would not shout white Power and I
probably would not swim with the dolphins. But
no, in all seriousness, I know winter, spring,
summer, the changes, the snow, the foliage.
And I get it. I've done it for decades and I
can still get winter if I'm in Florida, January
and February. Right. We still have winter in
December and to some degree March. Okay. So I
am thinking about for the purposes of spending
time outdoors and beach and all these different
things, mental health. Should I become a snowbird
many decades sooner than many people do, But no
decisions have been made as of this time. We have
a great bonus show. On the bonus show, we will
talk about remote work costing Manhattan more
than $12 billion a year. We will talk about the
CDC reporting that teen girls are in an extreme
wave of sadness and violence. What is causing it?
What can and should be done? And we will also talk
about teacher salaries increasingly becoming a
bipartisan cause. Low pay is being agreed upon as
a major crisis in education. All of those stories
and more today, not tomorrow, not some other day
in the future. Today on the bonus show, sign up
at Join Pacman Dotcom. I look forward to seeing.